the angry bagel guy is calling in yes
Chris and what I'm glad that you're
calling in Chris because I was a little
worried about you because I saw somebody
sent me a tweet that your Twitter
account that was run by your management
team you guys remember Chris the angry
bagel guy it was in the video and then
he's been in studio a couple times he's
hung out with Mary Jean but you had a
management team that came with you when
you were in studio and the tweet came
out that said that you and your
management team had parted ways and that
you were no longer part of your Twitter
account that's correct so a day won't
give you the Twitter account well I'm
not allowed to mention their name
anymore but we're basically you know
parted ways you know peacefully but you
know it didn't sound peaceful the way
they described it it sounded like as
they were is an ugly breakup and that
they felt mistreated no no that's
totally inaccurate first of all I was I
was living in the Florida room of
Shawn's house
he was very verbally constantly abusive
to me saying I'll punch your [ __ ]
face just to be an [ __ ]
this other guy heard the whole
conversation when we were on the phone
to him you know and basically they took
a picture one day and me and my
underwear and they never [ __ ]
authorized and publicized all over the
in at cowboy
it was videotaping me sleeping they'd
have a [ __ ] item [ __ ] authorized it
right okay then so but anyway you know
basically it was the whole thing it's a
disagreement we're not doing business
anymore
your new Twitter is are at King Chris
Morgan that's my Twitter it's gonna be
everything when they remake all the
pages I they never even gave you access
the past comes to my own [ __ ] right you
know what they were posting I don't
trust them anymore oh I want to give you
your Twitter account like it I mean
there's really no there's nothing they
can get out of it have you asked them
for it exactly that's what me and my
friends was like what the [ __ ] a
gaining energy [ __ ] nothing but anyway
no Mike the one other guy I'm working
with who's going to be an investor who
then deal with the particular reasons
not mention in his name we kind of
branched off I'm handling everything on
my own with him and that's when we're
working with each other solely now
are you getting your are you getting
your cameo money I know you're doing a
bunch of cameos is that going through
the old oh I haven't no I used to do
them I don't I don't do them no more
how come yes well they before I
supported wage they died down the cameos
like wasn't any left so if there is any
I I'm not aware about it okay okay well
you know you're not doing that you are
seeing the money from them no no they
paid me all up for whatever the old okay
alright that's good I always worry about
that stuff
so again yeah the Twitter was at King
Chris Morgan everything's gonna be king
Chris Morgan as you as a crown that's
the picture is you at the crown Chris
you should really you should be in on
that you should you should make sure
that this is the right one and you're
giving out the right one you got to be
hands-on with your career you got to be
hands-on oh no I am clean the cleaning
company I have my name is clear view
cleaning right
the number six three one okay no five
okay seven seven two three nine if
anybody needs their house or you know
business clean I do that okay clear view
cleaning right so next three one eight
eight oh five seven two screen right now
in your life I've done retorts and Mary
jeans BS oh okay all right this is good
okay well I'm glad you're calling me
because yesterday we talked to Mary Jean
on ok good I'm gonna just let everybody
who didn't want to update people who
have not met it have heard that segment
yeah Mary Jean called and we talked to
her for a few minutes yesterday our
friend Mary Jean because Chris has been
hanging out with her he met her here on
the show a couple of weeks ago they hit
it off Mary Jean is a very very
beautiful woman
she did adult film star she is Chris's
type Chris was in here talking about how
he liked large breasts he liked big
booty he liked all that sand Mary jeans
got all of that so they hit it off Chris
ended up going to marry jeans beauty
salon that she runs
and from what we heard Chris showed up
very very early two hours before the
store even opened
hey they am yeah at 8 a.m. and then Mary
said that she didn't say the
relationship was bad but she did say
there were multiple occasions that she
had to block your phone number because
you would not stop texting her and
insisting on answers immediate and I did
ask her Chris if you were actually I
didn't know I said was he being a dick
who is he just being a little overeager
and she goes he was really nice just a
little overeager so she didn't [ __ ] on
you but she did block I know that soccer
status no what no that's that's that's a
lie I didn't tell her they aired to me
now I have screenshots of some of our
text anyway that I have on my phone ha
and I had the vision well anyway here's
the deal so she starts at the day that
we met when we left the studio and we
went like our ways she goes so nice
meeting you and that's all right I'll
see you soon and if she starts attaching
hearts right away so I was like all
right whatever so then she eventually
starts calling me and texting babe like
what would any guy think when food you
know you talk to me the way you do on
the show all the sexual things she would
say and then cause she's saying sexually
yes what's she saying my tits and then
when I was imitating hitting the bong
and she said oh I thought that's how he
meant oh he was gonna eat my click like
come on
I see right I see she's got you all work
yeah yeah she goes you know she one day
I'm at a park in Long Island Never Knows
he goes you know can you come by
tomorrow to hang out this is okay it's
not in she texted me a few minutes later
saying oh actually I got to come in
today come in today it's okay that's
when I went in and I heard her I bought
everybody treats that she gave me all
the click the services of her salon so
everything went great I love so
grandmother I loved her mother we all
got a great so you're thinking that the
family you're thinking right you're
thinking number one we already talked
about you know cunnilingus we already
talked about you know looking at breasts
and everything Seton [ __ ] sucking
sure now I've met the family
so clearly I'm auntie I was invited to
the beauty salon
I met her whole family we discussed
cunnilingus yeah clearly something is
popping off here right well I obviously
he's beautiful and every guy in the
world probably wants to you know with
her but I from meeting her personality
you know some people you almost feel
like an immediate chemistry it's beyond
a look sure I really liked her family I
like her a lot you know so would you say
Chris that like and I don't want to put
like a word on it but would you say it
was starting to become love it was yeah
yeah absolutely yeah yeah especially
meeting the family I mean I've been
friends of Mary Jean for five years I've
never met her family Wow really no yeah
no Wow yeah I mean I've known her I've
known her for a long time too she's
she's been great friends with the show
sure did has tried to grab my genitals
on occasion you have not allowed it sure
but I've also I've never never I've
never met her family and I don't even
think we've discussed cunnilingus in in
those kind of details to tell you the
truth yeah all right well in any event
well we didn't we never spoke anything
about that outside of the show but oh so
what happened was one day I decided I go
let me let me show up just a surprise
you know it's a nice thing so you know I
left my little you know I know i thought
she opened at ten o'clock right so I get
there early now there's a store like a
place to eat next to her is where this
old man was bringing all the sodas and I
felt bad and I'm like oh let me help
this guy
so I thought when I start bringing all
the food in for that you know whatever
like for the stock and then the place
the eatery near her nuevo something I
became friendly with them and once they
know anyway so I was helping I was
helping the the old man
bring all this stuff in you know because
he was an old guy and they love me and
they I got a bunch of stuff there they
only charge me 10 bucks so now the shop
opens and I had flowers with me and the
mother oh my god she's like oh and she's
not coming in for there it says well so
eventually I hung out with the mom for a
while Mary Jane's mom just hung out
there
so let me ask you this Chris cuz I get
what you're like what time of morning is
this wait let me tell the story so then
so then I was out in the front of the
store like trying to help get costumers
and stuff you know wow wow we have to
ask Howard Howard what are you doing
well in other words like if people
walking Michael how you doing strike up
a conversation sure like you know me I
was on you know the bago that oh yeah
and then like this is my friends Paul
I'm like they did a great service and
nice people you know if you you know if
you ever want to get serviced on me you
can take all the folders with me you
want kind of like a bargain thing trying
to help them with this like hey you get
a photo with me if you patronize my
friends business yeah so I'm sure a
couple people go in and answer some
questions about their services I brought
them in that I just go as her meaning
her mom right I literally got them then
the thought of talk to them what did it
really what did the mom say when you
were kind of just there hanging out was
she happy to see you is she a little
confused no I'm confused as a matter of
fact I even I even asked her I says oh
you know when Mary sign out and you're
like she's not like freaked out is she
okay because if not only shares know
you're okay I says okay and oh it's a
matter of fact the first time I was
there I wanted to leave and she said I
cleaned the shop which I did but not
because I didn't want to leave I
actually wanted to leave three times
he's always tired and she kept saying no
don't go the third time she grabbed my
wrist who did the mom or Mary no Mary
anyway you stay here I'm like okay oh
[ __ ] number one on that did you start to
think Chris because the way I'm getting
this and I start I'm pretty good with
vibes did you start to think you know
this could be a potential boyfriend
girlfriend situation might be the
makings of relationship yeah okay so so
after I'd left the shop she was texting
me and she's like oh my dog you know
she's like you were at the shock oh my
god you got me flowers - no way buh buh
buh so that she was let me go I want to
face my my mom so I can see the flowers
she did it I heard she put the pictures
of it on a page I figured everything was
cool so now about three days goes by and
I go uh you know hello you know good
morning
nothing after 3-4 days I asked I said I
like to take you to a nice dinner and
maybe some golfing someday if you're
interested dinner and golf yeah that's
nice great and she's not available voice
we'll go out with you don't know it so
now the fourth day comes and finally
that's when she texted me oh we gotta
talk and I'm like we gotta talk and the
less is you know what I want I can read
the text verbatim if you want me to well
did you put on did you post this YouTube
video of the texts all you see it right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's seems to be a YouTube video
tweeted from your your link yeah you
tweeted a link to a YouTube video and it
is your entire conversation with Mary
Jesus I also yeah I also tweeted like
some response videos but again when I
was there when I was there the first
time okay I went in on making a video
this was a salon if you she's got I got
about four inside videos nobody's seen
when I was there she saw he jumping up
and down like a child then if I come out
of the bathroom her and a friend Oh turn
around and shaking their ass at me I'm
like what the [ __ ] is all this
provocative [ __ ] so after she blocked me
I'm like what's with all this why you
teasing me are you just out for my cloud
III cold ride Epson [ __ ] now I'm pissed
that you did you called her effing [ __ ]
and you but you did say he used a word
or did you say yes ' and no no you've
seen all those we haven't read them yet
well after you see like the three hearts
is right around when she blocked me
because I could tell she blocked me
because when you send someone a text you
see that it was delivered and then read
well that wasn't even say delivered and
I put two and two together go well she
blocked me over for text okay let me let
me read a little bit of this Chris
you're you texted her start at the
beginning
you called her okay here yeah so you
sent her a smiley face yep
this is on Saturday 4:25 p.m. right and
then you wrote hope you're okay haven't
heard from you in like four days lol got
a comedy show tonight some other
appearance gigs - well the bookings are
rolling in I'm no longer working with
Langley -
the names out right so I'm working with
Bill and Romeo how have you oh good
you're putting your here in the hands of
Romeo blue he's good and then you wrote
you wrote just like you said I'd like to
take you to a nice dinner sometime and
golfing if you are interested you did
say that okay and you that was it that
was Saturday now no response Monday
comes around right hang on hang on right
let's go back to what Monday comes
around you right I guess you're not
coming on the fishing trip just please
yeah weird go ahead might I have a
friend of mine whose friend I just met
as a boat oh we had planned she was very
excited and she was she's like uh we
planned for October 5th
so I told I says this is about a few
days before this I says you know we got
to be take the cheese if you're gonna
drive out meet me in Freeport you gotta
be here at 5:00 a.m. never respond she
said she wanted to go on the trip just
gonna she would texted me why bye oh
well you know I just let me know because
I'm gonna I'll bring somebody else
and she goes oh tell that she's
something was a girl she was care abouts
what I'm going that's why she collected
me but I don't have a shot at that okay
she goes I'm definitely in I'm so
excited I can't wait how come you don't
well how'd you lose the screenshot of
that you know weird was I scroll up now
some of the texts are gone like like
they're not there no way I get in
contact with Tim Cook on that maybe we
were you may be a little tipsy and you
deleted them in anger frustrated rage
okay so let me didn't respond we got an
update I guess you got coming on the
fishing trip just please let me know so
I can invite my friend then please and
then she responded yeah she wrote she
wrote I'm not gonna be able to go we
need to talk right now I'm running late
I'm dealing with some stuff that seems
reasonable seems reasonable yeah well
she just said she can't talk right now
and then it looks like you responded yes
we do this goes both ways
cuz I'm dying to know just what the hell
I did to you besides being a gentleman
and by the way it's always about you
dealing with stuff so have I ever
I bought you [ __ ] flowers you ghosted
me something I don't take nicely babe
heart heart heart it does seem like
you're flying off the handle a little
bit it seems like you're being a little
angry over look no guy wants to hear
from a honker no guy wants to hear hey
I've got some [ __ ] going on it's a
little you know no guy likes that but if
someone at least answered you and told
you that this seemed reasonable
sometimes they have [ __ ] going yeah no
no that's because she reminds me of all
have all these women I had 3 me on my
life and yeah but you can't take out
your past traumas on Mary Jean yeah Mary
that's not fair to come in and explain
and then get mad at her cause her stuff
other people did no no no well if you
let me get someone I'm getting this
alright so what she's watching what I'm
relating to what she's done how she's
behaved relates that what has the only
other woman have like like [ __ ] with my
mind so between her call me big hearts
shaking her ass on these videos and
after four little texts it's like you
blocked me I'm like I bought you flowers
it was good too you're failing you
blocked me up stuff over text like what
the [ __ ] is that
that's overreacting well I think I think
it's because it continued after the
after the babe like you weren't done
yelling at her for telling her that she
had some [ __ ] going on you wrote all
that teasing from you why did you ever
talk to me hmm and don't text me that I
just wanted to be friends [ __ ]
either cloud chaser you women just love
lying manipulating me [ __ ] with my
head emotions I must be the most ugliest
and pathetic sucker on earth then I've
done nothing but treat you and your
family and co-workers with love and
respect and tried getting you customers
but yet this is your retort amazing and
telling me on Norton show by the way
Chris that we do have to talk about the
name but that's bad
hi Chris got the name right Wow Chris is
a good boy is an issue but telling me uh
Norton the show right are you saying
should be the Jim Norton show the Jim no
no I mean it's the same it happened at
the comedy show - but wait that's
besides the point you love me stare at
my tits oh that's how I thought he was
going
while you wrote to eat my cliff yeah
pressing your ass up against me while
taking pics after the show but it's just
friends right now all these texts for
question marks are coming one after
another after another after another
after another after she said we have to
talk but I'm busy right now
right uh you know I've got a I've got to
deal with some stuff so you could see
one more there oh there is yeah oh and
then yeah oh and shaking your ass at me
at your shop but I shouldn't assume you
like me right
now she hadn't responded to any of these
no because that's what she's had me
blocked basically I think she's like
what is he really doing what is she up
to
you know what I mean like is this old
[ __ ] just to [ __ ] get me to 500
wide mug cuz I got way more viewers then
oh well you know what she was doing
yesterday what happened you know what
she was doing yesterday
no she's hanging out with Troy oh well
oh did you see margin yesterday san
gennaro I just saw it on Instagram
that's why I was like so Mary's doing
fine oh yeah she seems great okay good
you guys had a good time yeah okay good
good good good I just wanted to make
sure that Mary Jean wasn't destroyed I
was worried that all this was stressing
around but she's totally fine
oh she's fine did she bring this up she
mentioned him briefly but just kind of
in passing no anyway what are you saying
Chris it just seems like women and
generally just like do whatever they
want act the way they want and then when
we do anything that's what she's acting
like these girls on dating sites that
are overly sensitive like one little
thing annoys them or you send two texts
in like a minute
they're like think they'd run away like
like what is happening to people today
they're so overly sensitive enjoying
[ __ ] [ __ ] like this one
[ __ ] off and grunt yet you know anyway
yeah it's gross them [ __ ] skin for
god sakes like one little thing that
kicks them look they forget about all
the good [ __ ] they see that you do for
them it sucks oh wait let me ask you
Chris you sent these text messages and
did she for she got after you shaking
your ass at me but I'll assume you met
you liked me right what happened after
that look
you want to read you some more text or
sroi has them kids let him play we're
trying to get to today oh the rest of
that is vocal responses from crawl okay
so where did you leave it with her young
good terms shaking your ass tell me Bobo
okay then okay this is the sex that you
didn't see real quick I mainly told her
that I'm sorry that I snapped but I
think you're acting ridiculous prove me
wrong I've been used all my life but you
say i text you too much you're going to
show you make me look like an ass
I told it's of the flowers up her ass oh
wow and basically I dress like or Isis
you said I don't want to leave the shop
because I don't want to leave I said no
stupid like that no I explained that she
wanted me to say that basically and then
I want to talk to you you're a [ __ ]
tease you don't [ __ ] answer my [ __ ]
Wow [ __ ] days not a Hello that's
basically yet what do you think this do
you think that there's at all a
possibility that maybe maybe you came on
a little strong not at all he came on
strong with me on the [ __ ] show my
friend dick and [ __ ] come on dude
he's hanging my romeo huh you tearing my
Romeo on the show right Romeo never went
to a salon do you do you think possibly
you got matador too fast like she might
have had some [ __ ] going on and maybe
you got a little angry just cuz you were
because it was [ __ ] other people have
done like the egg whites thing I'm not
mad that she's gonna [ __ ] come on I made
that after I bought it for I was 40 I'm
like eh you okay
you know I was concerned about it you
know and then I see she's reading and
also she's not responding I'm like she
won't even give me an explanation this
is Oh before she finally told me we need
to talk I'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on right like you don't even say you're
damn good morning and she's always I'm
busy you know like she's really busy I'm
like I don't buy that crap everybody's
busy everybody starts [ __ ] going on you
can't pick up the phone for five seconds
inside GM gave me a [ __ ] break I
don't buy that [ __ ] now don't push them
in Chris do you ever think to yourself
why do
I feel like I'm more angry than the
average person now do you think she
meant to manipulate you she doesn't seem
like that type does she see like I
didn't read that either yeah do you
think that she meant to oh I didn't
either but now for how to overreact over
a couple of cats driving her crazy like
there are people that drove me crazy
I didn't block them well you told them
to put the flowers up although you did
you did block the one guy you had been
in business with you remember he
responded to you an hour later but you
had blocked him that's true oh oh that
you haven't it was a YouTube video
you're outside his house yelling out
okay she owed you money you said you
[ __ ] dirtbag scumbag that's true
and Jim is right about that you did
block him after about two hours of
conversation and he said I was trying to
pay you back but you'd bought me we were
going over like like that like an
invoice and he wasn't like responding to
something or something I know I blocked
them and I'm like where's this invoice
that I you claim I owe you thousand well
in that video when you scroll around for
the comments when that first came out
there's a guy that knew him and he wrote
this whole paragraph that that guy was
corrupt he loved a lot of people's homes
demolished he took their deposit never
[ __ ] fix their home so eventually he
was unlicensed they busted in his office
they posted him and took all his
computers I didn't know that that's
neither here nor there but where where
do you think you are right now with Mary
Jeanne are we trying to make this right
there you try to make it yeah let's go
where are you trying to make up or has
she got back to you no she's an answer
she sees all the text and call her
enough and [ __ ] she's probably not
gonna order but you know last time
that's funny cuz let me tell you
something I I mean I really really liked
her a lot
yeah hold on I think up your parents are
awesome I your families I collected it I
love your family they're awesome they're
so cool but sometimes I would just here
and there touch something and she just
want to respond and I'm so sick of the
stupid [ __ ] but sometimes because
that maybe you gotta give people a
little leeway to be like you know we're
all [ __ ] up so sometimes maybe when
you meet
you got to realize they're bringing in
baggage and you're bringing in baggage
and and sometimes you got to give people
a little bit of leeway
you know things develop slowly no no I
totally agree with that and that's fine
but the fact that just not the main
thing that hurts me is that not a hollow
is for dates like come on not even a
good like to me that's just [ __ ] rude
and that's what set me off but you know
did you Chris generations are changing
you also you know you strike me as a guy
who's quick to get into a relationship
nowadays you know you you're meeting
more people you're talking to more
people you hang out with somebody you
can go a couple days without talking to
them again that yeah absolutely I don't
have just a jet hey anything even when I
asked at a dinner like do you want to
maybe get dinner and go golfing I know
answer I don't I know one thing I
[ __ ] hate is is is when you don't
respond and if I did come on a little
strong justifies you so as I told you
the way she was talking to me on your
show and then shake it I am only answer
when I go to see you on the show I will
show them to you off the air the videos
I made a her and her co-workers shaking
a [ __ ] ass his acting and then she's
washing my hair I made a video that
she's flicking a head and all high like
acting like oh like like like that this
happy kinder can saw that I'm there I'm
telling you I have a moment on my phone
dude yeah well she may be happy to see
you but that doesn't mean that she's
ready to jump into a committed
relationship with you yeah maybe she has
some other stuff going on and shake your
[ __ ] ass at me don't send hearts and
call me babe
Troy you were you were yes you were
hanging out with her yes at the festival
that's correct
no no no I was our staff member handsome
he's really good-looking guy tattoos
tall troy was hanging out with her
festival they serve food all that stuff
right yes okay what did she text her she
texted you back yeah okay that's cool
what did you say do you want to go to
the festival she said hey do you want to
go to the festival because it was right
down the block for me sure how should
she actually reached out to you see you
went had a good time
great that's great and she seemed to be
in a good place
yeah she was in a great place okay
that's great did she seem busy or not
that busy uh I mean I'm sure she has
stuff going on yeah you know the funny
thing is though like last night because
I was like hey have you seen the bago
they talked to him and said you know
she's tired she had nothing but nice
things that she didn't say one bad thing
about him which is interesting spoke
nicely of you Chris I feel like if I got
all these texts from somebody I was sure
I wouldn't feel good about them nothing
not one about he's a really sweet sweet
person yeah yeah Mary Jane yes she spoke
highly about you no no I heard the whole
thing like I said with the whole you
know like the stalking thing or whatever
or text I'm like oh you wouldn't know
you gotta answer me now I never said
that [ __ ] you're gonna answer me no no
but I mean even - even - Troy like in a
private at the festival when he asked
about you when they were hey yeah
yesterday yeah what she called you they
were uh she said nice things about you
well gosh [ __ ] thanks or nothing wait
Troy you saw her over the weekend as
well yes yeah she came out to see ya
Black Caviar oh they're doing a show
just a one time she's seen us three
tests the third time she came in sauce
and the facts are you've hung out with
her four times recently I was in the
past couple months yeah sure
Wow okay so she is around yeah that's
great
she's a good time right why yes she is
Chris if she just shakes her ass at you
why do you think that she owes you a
good morning whenever you want it it's a
good point do you think it's normal for
a girl to shake your ass other guys
she's not dating
that's manipulation especially at me
when she knows I'm you know like like
this possible clout and exposure for her
in this but Chris let me ask you this
but tell me this you're being I feel
like you're being pessimist yeah because
and I'll tell you why because you might
think it's not normal for a girl to
shake her ass at you if she's not dating
you but I don't but what isn't it nice
to have a girl shaking her rear end at
you isn't that a nice things never a bad
thing like no one's ever I don't care
whose acid is either right right I don't
care if I'm in a hospice and she's
shaking
for other reasons so instead of instead
of being mad at meri for as you say
leading you on couldn't you be grateful
that she she shook her rear end at you
she showed you some attention and you're
flirting she's flirting kind fun
sometimes it's just fun to flirt no well
yeah I mean any especially her I mean
who wouldn't want someone like her to
[ __ ] shake their ass out of bush what
sounds like if she doesn't if she's not
ready to marry you you don't want that
yeah I didn't marriage but you know like
I said golfing what's been done to me in
the past yeah it's like I don't know man
I just feel like she she knows I like
her Smokey's and me I don't [ __ ] a
freak I think you're the past yet to all
of us our past sometimes creeps in
knowing and it [ __ ] up the the present
well like I was gonna get a tattoo years
ago because I like to flirt and it was
gonna be like a little flirt
l ' i l flirt I want to get a little
flirt tattooed cuz I like to flirt I
still think you should I know because
you are a kind of a flirt
yeah and at first I'll tell you but my
taint I was gonna say before because but
yeah I mean I couldn't it just be like
you know Chris I think that you got a
maybe just realize that some
relationships are a little bit more
casual sure than what you're ready for
and sometimes you know somebody like
Mary Jean might just have fun having you
as a friend and then maybe it develops
into something sometimes these things
develop how long have you been friends
Mary Jane twitter's Troy's been friends
with Mary Jean for years and they're
just to hang out do friends for years
you're friends with Mary Jean right I am
yeah it's not like you and Mary Jean
have Jacuzzi nude together have you we
have indeed yeah okay however we did not
have sex
ahh we did you koozie knew we did not
have sex okay all right that's actually
great to bring up Chris you hear this
this is Jim Norton who you decided the
show is named after solely Jim had an
experience with Mary Jean Mary Jean
talked about how much she loves Jim I
love you Jim I love
jim-jim said thank you that's very nice
of you to say she came over to his
apartment she got naked and jumped in
his jacuzzi with him and he and had him
get naked - yes my clothes were off and
they didn't have intercourse we did not
have intercourse and instead of Jim
saying instead of Jim saying instead of
Jim you know saying nasty things about
her and saying that she's a Jim Norton
cloud chaser Jim said you know what but
instead of Jim saying that about himself
Jim said you know what I just had a what
a wonderful rendezvous a delightful time
in the jacuzzi and I drained the water
and smelled the seat where she'd been
sitting and I masturbated and that's it
and he's got that experience I came on
Mike it might damage your coochie floor
you know she's you know what now don't
text me unless you're interested [ __ ]
me that's it that's what I told them
okay see that's a little you put on the
table that's a little severe like dog
window I appreciate that about you but
don't you think that don't you don't you
think there is some merit don't you
think that there's some okay don't you
think there's some merit to Jim's
strategy which is oh we had a good time
naked in a Jacuzzi I'm not mad that my
penis wasn't in her yeah I didn't care
no but she didn't say that we were gonna
[ __ ] we just hired but like here I'm
gonna call the judge so Michael the
video you on drugs
yes so you're saying here Jim is a
little left of center Jim's a little
wacky for not getting pissed I didn't
care I just tuck my penis later I forget
my press for it right Chris you were
hanging out with Mary Jean last night
right I was yeah all right Chris you
happen to bump into her down there right
I know she was like hey let's hang out
engineer fest and we yeah she said
again cuz like so yes and you responded
okay and you did hang out again yeah we
hung out on there a turday night call on
Saturday as well
yeah because she came to the Black
Caviar Show wow that's twice over the
course of like three four days okay that
is correct
Chris did you have you ever thought to
yourself that it's crazy that this
gorgeous girl is giving me attention and
maybe I should have a little strategy is
that a high joke
little no okay good don't do that to
Chris okay do you ever think yourself
like this girl is way way out of my
league maybe I should just have a little
strategy and play things a little
different play a little cool don't don't
come across so desperate and when things
don't go exactly the way that you think
that they should go right maybe you just
back off a little bit and give her a
little space and you know maybe it works
out maybe she doesn't but but it's all
good either way
it's all good yeah it's so angry maybe
maybe two three weeks go away go by and
she goes out let me hit up Chris let's
hang out again right maybe she's busy
have you ever thought that that could be
a possibility well it was but it's all
the [ __ ] I said she brought me he's
gonna call me no more now some of the
last things you said were the last few
texts well I think the last thing I said
it was from now on don't talk to me
unless you want to [ __ ] me that's it
okay yeah you might want to amend that
and Concord or [ __ ] war okay that's
tough why don't you text her again and
say Mary I've reconsidered my initial
offer if you'd like to talk I won't
consider it you know grounds for you
wanting to have sex maybe you'd like to
go for some dessert or a cup of joe
that's actually a good way to phrase it
no I happy horseshit no more I want to
bang her that's it okay it's a line in
the sand it is it's against and it's
fair that you're being honest but you
could see where she would find that less
than charming goddamn Pig okay well I
don't think that that's probably gonna
happen at this point
well you know what that's fine but you
know I feel like I was teased you know I
mean hanging out gigging shake it come
on like I just met you so you think that
that her shaking her ass at you was
promise it was so the fact that she was
provocative that's a promise for
intercourse yeah I see you know
considering what she does for a living
and stripping and you know that's a
little judgmental you might be judge and
what happens is these girls always have
guys expect to just want to [ __ ] them
sometimes they want to [ __ ] you more if
you're not pursuing them so aggressively
the [ __ ] is and they get to know you and
they like you this is a guy I would I
would have sex with he's not like every
other guy yeah I mean think about it
this way Troy didn't hit her up she hit
up try I would imagine that the reason
Mary Jean on some level keeps hitting up
Troy to hang out with him is she
probably would like to have sex with
Troy sure don't you think so I would
assume so
yeah I would think how could you not
yeah and some he's funny yeah that makes
me feel so much better you know how
would you feel if you buy flowers I did
not no no do you bite pay for dinner no
actually she she bought dinner last
night and I'm watching all the taller
guys always get these women how tall are
you right six - wow that's tall I'm
sorry see he'll want me [ __ ]
manipulating for my [ __ ] height and I
know six - Troy yeah Wow
hey do you have problems with women
usually no being a DJ helps yeah you
also try to have a little bit of stomach
when you're really attracted to somebody
you try to have a little bit of a
strategy instead of just when this
person doesn't act exactly the way I
feel that they should act at this exact
moment you just fly off the rails and
just sink the ship you got it you gotta
have a long-term strategy if you're
really interested in somebody well he
just wants to have intercourse with her
repeatedly did you just get a hooker
have you thought about that Chris
getting yourself a nice baby I'm paying
somebody to uproot on your penis I used
to do that when I was younger but you
know what to me that's degrading it's
like I gotta pay for it like no I don't
like that where would you go
I wanna ha i wanna ha listen I think you
helped my whole life I [ __ ] deserve
somebody a DA damn hot is hot and you
like AB and you like her breasts what
they're her breasts of the right size
yeah I'm a breast night but I listen I
think you well I'm a decent looking guy
handsome III I feel I deserve a goddamn
good-looking hot chick
they'll want the fool of me and [ __ ] me
a lot would you give yourself I'm tired
of watching poor guys always get them
not to me too buddy what would you if
now what would you give yourself on a 1
to 10 what do you mean you mean looks
and everything yeah yeah I'd say about a
like maybe a 7 that's fair that's good
that's fair
yeah it's not too crazy but it shows a
good amount of self esteem I'd say 7 is
accurate mr. Nate Chris do you ever even
okay do you ever worry that you might be
suffering from some entitlement issues
some what is it
entitlement what do you mean the way you
feel like you are entitled to certain
things whether it be a certain caliber
of a woman and you know oh absolutely I
do yes and that's a good thing but after
all that [ __ ] what [ __ ] you say
all the [ __ ] you said you've dealt
with I mean after a while you just get
frustrated yeah because I feel I deserve
a [ __ ] good looking girl a cheque man
I'm tired of settling for you know girls
that don't work and they're [ __ ] sad
or and then it all this [ __ ] I'm tired
of I deserve a [ __ ] and ever since
and I under fill you guys in on
something tell me I've only had sex with
one person since the bagel thing
happened and all the woman wasn't even
that great looking oh all this other
[ __ ] all these women I met wherever I
have not had sex with one hot girl not
one and I said let me tell you okay I've
actually got mad tea right over this
said I don't want to like things like
you know you know you thought to think
everybody thinks I don't want to live
anymore like suck [ __ ] because it's true
I'm tired of this [ __ ] that Chris are
you everybody everybody has without the
[ __ ] lying use me like a cloud chaser
everybody I wish I can't be okay let me
ask you this Chris cuz I don't want you
to be suicidal because hens won't have
sex with you that doesn't seem healthy
trust me if that was that's the way it
should have been I would have been dead
in 1988 but you the way you feel like
based on the fact that you're famous you
are you trying to use your face
to get women that are better looking
than you would get normally so if you're
using your fame to get that how can you
be mad when you meet women that also
want to use your fame like if they go if
you're if you're saying hey look I'm
famous you should [ __ ] me and they go
alright you're famous maybe I'll [ __ ]
you and then you get mad at them hey
you're only [ __ ] making some famous
right they want to use my fame go right
ahead but make sure you [ __ ] me I think
they use me but yeah I'm not going for
this [ __ ] that's why I'm exploding I
have not had one [ __ ] hot girl since
this happened nobody and you sorry you
side why don't you do this do you how do
you have a tinder profile maybe some
dating profiles and then maybe I'm on
well yeah well III had a tender nobody
was responding so I [ __ ] joy joy to
leave a dad I'm on OkCupid right oh by
the way I forgot to tell you guys this I
was on there last night somebody is
using Mary genes [ __ ] picture humble
yeah you see and people might be think
that it's not you well that's just
somebody using your photo so maybe you
just be patient it's her I because I
reported it I says I know this person
and this person's got to be used it's a
picture of her like like like putting
her hand behind a head like behind the
wheel as she's driving I'm like holy
[ __ ] like that cannot be really up you
know it's hot but it's someone else
using her [ __ ] picture I see I know
maybe I read the whole profile I'm like
[ __ ] man
but uh Chris come on OkCupid I have nine
lights nobody I recently had a
conversation with this person who I was
speaking over like a year ago okay he
doesn't remember so I told him who I am
now and then she's like oh where'd you
go I'm like oh I'm right here you want
my number sure so all of a sudden
feelings playing she deletes me what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] man maybe maybe she
got intimidated oh well maybe she got
intimidated
yeah you know what's weird a lot listen
I've got a lot of hot girls and then
they took we exchanged numbers and some
of my friends said I don't think it's
the height like a 1 what is it they go
maybe they got freaked out they talked
to that family and maybe they don't want
the publicity I'm like oh what if it's
your what is it what if it's your anger
no I'm talking about
one where I didn't get angry like maybe
they didn't think back down but they can
look you up and they might think hey if
I don't [ __ ] this guy remedial he's
gonna yell at me publicly and they just
like I don't need that you are prone to
anger well that could be - maybe that is
the case I don't know but even before I
became famous I mean Sher Singh saying
[ __ ] like Olson they disappear like
where'd they go Chris do you think they
with Mary Jean and maybe some other
girls that you could possibly come off a
little crazy who wouldn't do you think
that if you come off like Chris do you
think if you come off like a psychopath
that a girl may say that she doesn't
want you to enter her vagina do you
think that could be a turn-off to women
coming across like a complete psychopath
theoretically of course yeah but listen
right I'm not a psychopath
you know at all I'm just tired of being
manipulated lied to you know and and and
I kind of sort like developing in that
way because it reminded me of how I was
treated by others in the past like that
so that's what I thought she was doing
especially now you got to let that go a
little bit you gotta let that go a
little bit more even if you don't let it
go don't let it bleed into every new
perk cause she's a new person and
whoever else she meets a new person so
you can't look at her and blame her for
[ __ ] that other girls did Chris here's
the thing you are telling us that you
only want a girl who is hot because yes
you deserve a hot big-breasted woman
that's fair but at the same time at the
same time you're getting upset that
women are not choosing to allow you to
enter them because they're choosing for
their choosing guys that are more
physically attractive than you well I
don't know about that they're not
choosing that of course they already
said the height you know I mean taller
guys are more physically attractive than
shorter guys to women I don't know about
that have you found that to be the case
Chris well why don't you say what do you
say I don't know about that what's your
reason for saying that I want to hear it
what is it Jim it you know if women
judge that immediately I mean I've done
okay I'm not a giant guy I'm like five
five six five six and a half I know but
I'm talking about like six two or four
like which one you get paid well six to
kind of out does everybody but I don't
know if that's all they look for that
yeah a lot of times some years with
crazy people and porn all the time and
crazy people at the club
so sanity might be an appealing quality
to her quiet sanity she might like her
be funny be charming gem don't you think
being funny is important it's the only
thing that's ever gotten me laid is
being funny but I also think that you
can't get mad if women are choosing to
have sex with people that are more
physically attractive than you if you
only want to date tens that's true right
yeah sure I didn't say dude I've
listened
III didn't fill you in on this one I
love dating sites okay if I see a girl
where I like the face which is the first
most important thing to me and her hair
and then she's got you know she's gonna
have some projects I'm in now she's
overweight I'm willing to overlook that
now I got no dates with women and a
heavy to me and they weren't physically
attracted to me or I'm like well you've
got to be kidding me you're not with a
heavy hair oh honey it's funny you guys
listen I gave many for listen I gave
many heavy a girls a chance but I didn't
and I'm still hitting heavier girls up
on here all kinds true from from women
that look like Mary Gena to overweight
women and you know that's how I made
Howard Stern laugh was I went on the day
one time and she's a robot my
ex-boyfriend brought me to his private
island and I said of what peaches and
that's when Howard Stern did his you
know yeah yeah you know he's left oh
yeah [ __ ] wait Here I am trying to like
accept a bigger well in a mansion of
women and then it's like they did you
could meet here they are they're broke
they're not working they're overweight
I'm in better shape than they off Chris
let me ask you did you send them text
woman yeah do you send them text like
look the last heavy girl that kind of
might have blown you off or turned you
down did you send her text messages I
don't and and by the way
IIIi gave that site a rest for at least
six months I just went back on
long ago and there is a huge number of
the same [ __ ] moronic idiots on that
because they are too stupid shallow or
they're [ __ ] or it's a phony
dude it's ridiculous I just had an
argument one of them that I talked to
last year and [ __ ] she Suraj's you
know what no one's going to date a
[ __ ] [ __ ] rude crude y'all
whatever I'm like yeah you're approved
I go you want to keep a guy this is
against up a whole world out there I
want to keep a relationship with a man
all we want to do is eat and [ __ ] that's
it it's simple that's what men won hey
when is your army yeah when is your next
comedy show but yeah basically the clear
that you know the cleaning company I
wanted to promote okay the part of the
fight as you know is it's coming up when
is that the that's that's the 28th of
this month or 20th Saturday correct see
at the showboat in Atlantic City at 7:30
Chris is that gonna be a legit fight
because there are people worried that if
that fight is legit and not like you
know at least a little bit staged there
could be a death if it's it's legit it
could be a death that people are worried
there could be a death and that you
would be the person who would
unfortunately pass away it's what people
are worried about it that's what I've
read well I think I think Chris probably
do better than people think he's lending
thanks there's an athlete but Lenny
hasn't exactly taken complete care of
himself so you know I think you might
have the advantage
Lenny drew blood from Chris at a press
conference a by accident Chris wasn't
ready yeah are you are you intimidated
Chris are you scared no of course not
what I do this if I was right of course
now why would you be it's just a fight
yeah forward to seeing it yeah keep in
touch with us know what's going on and
we're sorry things didn't work out with
uh with with Mary Jean it happens but
good to know from Troy that she is still
yeah one more gemandsam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the SiriusXM attic